[Music]
you know please no please please don't
hurt him it's just a child please no
dark side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some consider to be
unnatural what did you do to it this
what did you do to it I protected him I
protected him if it wasn't for me he
would already be the head please
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Mandalorian video for
the secret plan that the empire has four
baby Yoda why do they want him so bad if
you're new to the channel I do videos
for all the episodes and Easter eggs
there's also big movie stuff obviously
coming up because it's December as I'm
posting this video we're doing a merch
giveaway too all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about what the Emperor wants with
baby Yoda on the video cursory spoiler
warning for everything that's happened
on the Mandalorians so far most of what
we're talking about deals with stuff
from episodes 2 & 3 but there are a
couple other clues from the other
episodes as well the most important baby
Yoda seen so far in terms of evil empire
plots in explaining what's going on are
from episodes 2 and episodes 3 during
episode 2 we get confirmation of a
detail that we already kind of knew
members of Yoda's race are all born
extremely force-sensitive and even
though he's still a baby by the
standards of his race or a youngling
whatever you want to call him he's
already super powerful holding the giant
mud horn that probably weighs a hundred
times what he does in the air for an
extended period of time before he
collapses from the strain a lot of
people at the end of episode 4 also
thought that he would be able to use the
force to instinctively deflect the
Bounty Hunter's rifle shot but I don't
think that's the case I think he's only
able to perform those great feats like
the mud horn when he concentrates very
hard and even that put him down for
about half a day yes he does seem like
he has ninja-like powers of
teleportation and instant transmission
if we're talking about Dragon Ball
skills appearing out of thin air to
break the tension by slurping his soup
those are all really funny but that's
more of an editing cheat that the show
uses in the name of comedy during
episode 1 in episode 3 you hear dr.
Pershing talk about the kid in a really
important way it was very important to
him that he get him back alive and was
extremely excited when his scans showed
that he was super healthy as if that
would somehow be even better for the
Empire's plans Verner Herzog's character
who seems like an important person
within the remnants of the Empire seemed
like he could care less whether or not
baby Yoda was brought back alive and
didn't seem like he was on very good
terms with dr. Pershing like he didn't
enjoy working with him the way the
doctor was reacting to everything
especially during episode when we first
meet him just makes it seem like he's
really jumpy around the stormtroopers
like he doesn't like being here working
with these people even though he himself
is also part of the Empire that coupled
with the idea that he wanted to protect
baby Yoda just makes it seem like he has
a more complicated relationship with the
Empire yes he works for an evil
organization but he's not completely
evil himself I think that'll be more
important for later in the series but
we've all talked about the Kamino and
cloning symbols on Doctor Pershing's
Imperial uniform confirming that he
works at the cloning facility for the
Empire or he worked there for the Empire
when the Emperor was still alive
technically the Empire doesn't exist
anymore so all the Admirals in
higher-level officials like the moths
that were left in the wake of the
remnants of the Empire have seized what
power they could so technically the
Empire is still around but it's not the
empire that we knew before is a bunch of
different people calling the shots if
you haven't read a lot of the extended
and new Star Wars Canon there are a
bunch of new comics that tell you more
of what happened in and around the Clone
Wars supposedly according to the new
Darth Vader comics it's detailed that
after the Clone Wars in the last batch
of Republic clones had been delivered
the plan was for the Emperor to formally
shut down the cloning facility
completely no more clones for anyone but
cue Darth Plagueis the wise speech the
tragedy of Darth Plagueis the wise the
Emperor was obsessed with a couple
things one knowledge of the force to
immortality and three ruling the galaxy
you need a couple things to accomplish
all those goals you need a giant army
and you would need more clones there's
even an easter egg in the newer Star
Wars films where they talk about the
idea that they want to go back to using
clones for their armies because they
felt that they were more reliable than
the methods that are using in
present-day
the present day of the new films so the
whole idea is that all these Imperials
left around want more clones and the
Emperor was supposed to quote/unquote
have closed the cloning facility but I
think we can assume that he probably
didn't and he just kept it open as a
side project in secret some more
evidence that the cloning facility has
still been operating this whole time
during the course of the original
trilogy is that you look at the
stormtrooper
here five years after Return of the Jedi
look at their stormtrooper uniforms and
how decrepid and dirty they are either
they're just really crappy stormtroopers
and they don't care about keeping their
uniforms clean or this is just meant to
be a sign of the state of the Empire
everything is slowly crumbling to dust
the Empire itself is crumbling but dr.
Pershing is wearing this shiny brand-new
looking Imperial cloning uniform as if
he in the cloning facility beyond the
outer rim have been operating this whole
time insulated from the war with the
rebellion I think that's just
confirmation that the Emperor was
running a lot of secret cloning tests
and experiments on the side while this
is all going on so it's probably safe to
assume that this is all part of
Palpatine's grand plan but when he died
and you have all these warlords seizing
power a lot of Palpatine secret projects
were being co-opted by the Admirals and
the other moths that are left in the
wake of the Empire so here's a real
important distinction there I think some
things that are going on during rise of
Skywalker that seems similar to what
they're implying is going on in the
Mandalorian with baby Yoda in this
cloning facility but because of what JJ
Abrams and Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni
have said I think that the Mandalorian
TV show isn't directly going to connect
with what's happening in rise of
Skywalker it just seems like there are
some similarities and yes I do think
that baby Oda will survive into the
future and become the future of the Jedi
Order but before we talk about secret
baby here two plans I just don't think
the baby Yoda is gonna show up during
rise of Skywalker and save the day it's
not gonna be some deus ex machina or
anything like that because Yoda's race
is so powerful the emperor would have
loved to have been able to study his
biology in greater detail but couldn't
because Yoda would have discovered his
secret too early and revealed him and
then once he was revealed as Darth
Sidious Yoda had sequestered himself
secretly to Dagobah where the emperor
couldn't find him on the other side of
the galaxy
yeah doll had also disappeared after a
Phantom Menace and believed to be dead
so the emperor couldn't find her either
and they were the only two known members
of their race at that time now we know
that's not true because baby Yoda is
about 50 years old which means he was
born at about the same time that Anakin
Skywalker was meaning that he predates
the prequels and predates the creation
of the Clone Army in attack of the
clones which is why I don't think that
the kid is a clone of Yoda
I do think the doctor Pershing's
conversation with werner herzog in
episode 3 where he tells the doctor to
hurry up and get his samples than
dispose of the kid implies that he's
taking complete genetic scans of DNA
from the kid in order to create a new
clone army not necessarily a clone army
of tiny little Yoda's even though that
would be adorable the Kamino ins were
able to tamper with the genetic makeup
of the original clothes to give them
traits or take traits away from them
I think the plans for what they were
doing at the cloning facility changed
after the galaxies believed the Emperor
died during Return of the Jedi and the
Imperials left who seized what power
they could now want to use the cloning
facility in baby Yoda's DNA to create a
new army of super force sensitive clones
that they can control and clones that
have super long lifespans way longer
than normal humans I saw some people
reacting to this scene in particular
with him on the bio bed and thought that
the dr. Pershing was literally
extracting midi-chlorians from baby Yoda
that's not what he's doing you can't
take someone's midi-chlorians like you
can take their blood samples but you can
clone Jedi's they did it during legends
during the Thrawn Trilogy when the clone
of another Jedi Master cloned a new
version of Luke Skywalker using the
severed hand that he lost a cloud city
that the Emperor collected and then
later stored for use the clone of Luke
Skywalker even though it was a little
weird wound up being just as force
sensitive as the original version of
Luke and even though legends isn't
supposed to be canon anymore Dave Filoni
has recanted eyes a ton of legend stuff
Thrawn being the best example so it's
just an example that it is possible to
create a bunch of force sensitive clones
if you have the right DNA samples and
baby Yoda is one of the most
force-sensitive beings in the galaxy
because of his race but like I said I
don't think that what they're doing with
baby Yoda in the Mandalorian series is
directly connected to what's going on
with rise of Skywalker
I think the rise of Skywalker stuff is
completely separate for everyone asking
what's going on with baby Yoda in the
present day of the Star Wars timeline
you also have to remember that they aged
so slowly that even in present day 25
plus years when the new trilogy is
happening he'd still be very very young
he'd have to be closer to 80 or a
hundred years old before he'd be old
enough to begin any kind of formal Jedi
training or
thing like that and you have to remember
- there is no Jedi Order right now
they're just a couple of really force
sensitive people that will probably
slowly start coming together and rebuild
the Jedi Order but I do think that he is
critical to the future of the Jedi just
someone who can live and connect all the
different future generations because
he'll live so long you also have to
wonder if Giancarlo Esposito smoth
Gideon character is the one that's
behind this big cloning plot because he
used to be an imperial moth before the
fall of the empire now as Gina Carano
scare achter implies he's more of a
warlord who just taken command of all
the imperial assets that he could in the
sector so maybe he is the evil person
behind this plot because weirder
Herzog's character even though he seems
like he's a very important person
doesn't seem like the most important
person we still haven't gotten his name
but he is still alive he wasn't killed
at the end of episode 3 so it's implied
that he will come back at some point
early prediction they do get their hands
on baby Yoda at some point in dr.
Pershing is critical to them rescuing
baby Yoda and he winds up flipping sides
before the end of the series but
everyone posts all your theories in the
comments below what is their grand plan
for the cloning facility and baby Yoda
there'll be more Mandalorian bonus
videos this week post all your requests
in the comments below
congratulations gage Williams you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details
everyone click here for my Mandalorian
episode for video and click here for my
full history on the Mandalorian race
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]